this is a production of cornell
university
okay thank you so much hannah today i'll
be talking about genomic association
studies for cassava bronze check disease
and for those who do not know cassava
it is a bushy shrub that is grown for
its tubers around the world it feeds
about more than 800 million people most
of whom are in sub-saharan africa so uh
as you can see here cassava is growing
in different parts of the world don't
mind the shade of the green but i would
like to bring your attention to the
places in the dark green that's east and
central africa where cassava brown
straight disease is causing a enormous
yield losses that are threatening food
and economic security it also worries
breeders that the virus would move to
other cassava producing regions around
the world which would dry which would
further
increase food and economic security for
people so cassava brown strict disease
is a positive sense single-stranded rna
virus it's in the genus epoma virus and
family put by day we have two species of
this virus the cassava brown straight
paris and the uganda cassava bronzer
virus both cause similar symptoms that
lead to annual losses of 750 million in
uh uganda kenya tanzania and malawi so
to everyone cassava brown street disease
in the field we use the one-to-five
scoring method for assessing this
disease so both
the score is the score applies to both
folia and road symptoms so cbs defolia
symptoms are characterized by crosses
along the secondary uh vein margins
while in the root it shows up as dark
brown patches as necrotic lesions
so in the past data from this one to
five scoring method has been used in um
in trying to identify genomic regions
that are associated with cbsd phenotypes
so basically what happens is breeders
score it when a score of one indicates
there are no observable symptoms while a
score five is the highest severity
possible so
an example of such a study where the one
to five scoring method has been used to
try and identify genomic regions
associated with cassava bronze straight
disease is uh a study from zuki atl in
2017 where they did qtl mapping for
cassava
for cassava pests and disease so they
evaluated cassava brown straight disease
which i'm studying cassava mosaic
disease which is another virus disease
that affects cassava across africa and
asia and then the test that they studied
was the cassava green mite so they
generated a bi-parental population that
was made up by crossing
a variety called kirova which is a
landrus in tanzania that stresses its
origins back to the 1930s when breeders
started breeding for disease resistance
in cassava across east africa and ar 37
which is a breeding line so they ended
up with 106 um
f1 progeny that were tested
in two years across two locations so
they also developed a linkage map that
had more than 1500 snips and i used it
to identify qtls that were associated
with the two diseases and the pests so i
will concentrate on cassava brown
straight disease so for root necrosis
they identified two qtls that were on
chromosome 5 and chromosome 12 and these
ptls explain 10 percent of the
phenotypic virus that was observed while
for the four-year symptoms i scored at
uh three and six months after planting
they observed seven qtls that were on
chromosome 4 6 12 and 13 and these
explained eight percent of the
phenotypic variants so this group went
ahead to combine the root necrosis
scores and the folia scores and they
identified two ktls on chromosome 11 and
15.
so they later concluded that there was
consistence in some snips that had loads
caused greater than 2.5 but they also
observed that there was inconsistencies
in sniffs across locations so that means
that
a group of slips would show up in one
location but would then show up in
another location and they also concluded
that segments on chromosome 1
uh 12 and 13 were from the introductions
that were done in the 1930s and this
came from kirova which is a clone that
has some level of tolerance to cassava
brown strike disease so another study
where the one to five squaring method
has been used to try and identify
genomic regions associated with cassava
bronze straight disease is a study that
was done by caiondo echelle in 2018
where they did genomic association
mapping on two breeding panels uh and
tested these in five locations in uganda
so they evaluated cassava bronze
straight disease at three six and twelve
months after planting that's folia and
road symptoms and identified genomic
regions that were associated with these
phenotypes one of these regions was on
chromosome 11 for cbsd at three months
after planting and cbsd at six months
after planting so chrom snips on this
chrome on this this segment on
chromosome 11 explained six percent of
the phenotypic variance that was
observed so another region that was
identified in the study was on
chromosome four and this was later
associated to the introgressions that
were done in the 1930s this these
authors also reported inconsistencies in
snips across the five environments so
it's important to know that the genomic
regions that were have been identified
in both studies have never been
validated so this brings us to my
research where we are asking two
questions the first one is we want to
know which genomic regions are
associated with cassava brown straight
disease phenotypes in the cycle to
population of genomic selection and if
there are regions that we can identify
as their common snips
associated with these phenotypes across
the sibling and the clonal evaluation
trials so to give you an insight into
the psychotic population of genomic
selection these populations are
developed based on breeding values so we
use breeding values to estimate the
performance of parents that we use to
make process so this started with 52
clones that were selected from uh
tanzania the tanzanian breeding program
that were from the
sea at program and the international
institute of tropical agriculture in
nigeria so these 52 clones were
hybridized to create the c zero uh
population and from the c0 a subset of
100
clones were taken based on their
breeding values to create the cycle one
population and from the cycle one we
also got 95 clones that were hybridized
to create the cycle 2 which i am working
with now in the cycle two population we
ended up with uh six thousand seven
hundred seedlings that were planted in
one location and from these seedlings we
did subset uh 303 clones that were
advanced to the clonal evaluation trials
where we planted them uh using augmented
designs with five checks uh we evaluated
these 303 clones in two locations for
two years now because we're talking
about genome-wide association studies
uh our market data we worked with market
data that had 41 000 slips that were
from that sick genotyping uh we did the
one-step dues and they would and then we
used the fdr correction threshold so if
you look at the seedling trial which are
the six thousand clones when we did
viewers you can see that uh at three and
at three six and twelve months after
planting we see the same trend that we
see numerous hits across you know
different chromosomes for each trait so
it's important to note that for cbsd at
three months after planting the sleeps
that were identified explained eleven
percent of the phenotypic virus in the
seeding trial and then uh at six months
after planting this mix explained five
percent of the phenotypic virus and the
twelve months after planting forward
necrosis they explained seven percent of
the phenotypic virus that we observed
but we had asked another question that
are there any common genomic regions
across these three phenotypes and the
answer was yes we could see this on
chromosome 1 and on chromosome 14. so we
did the same thing for the clonal
evaluation trial and the same trend
happens that we see that numera we get
numerous hits on different chromosomes
for each phenotype so you could see that
for cbsd at three months after planting
the snips that we identified explained
16 percent of the phenotypic variance
that we observed which was much higher
than that of the sibling trial and the
same thing happens for six months after
planting where we see twelve percent of
the phenotypic virus being explained by
these meats and that 12 months after
planting it was 18 percent of the
phenotypic virus so the same question
was as if there were genomic regions
that were
consistent across the three time points
and here we only see one on chromosome
12. so we went ahead to ask is yes we've
identified these genomic regions but
they are sniffs you know in the sibling
trial and the clone evaluation trials
that are common across these three
phenotypes so we went ahead to check for
the ceiling trial all the snips that we
asked we we got for the three time
points we did not have any common snips
across these phenotypes and for the
cloner evaluation trial you could see
that uh for foliar symptoms those that
are evaluated at three and twelve months
after planting we only have four common
snips that are we only have four common
sleeps but we don't have any snips
between folia and the root symptoms so
we did also ask another question is if
there were common snips between the
sibling and the flower evaluation trial
and the answer is no we did not have any
common slips between the sibling and the
clone of evaluation trials so now that
we don't have any common snaps but have
common genomic regions we change the
question and ask are there common
genomic regions in our population with
those that have been published that's
suzuki and kayondo and here you can see
that uh
for
when we compare our results to those of
mizuki in 2018 you can see that for cbsd
three months after planting in the
seedling trial we do under 12 months
after planting we do have common genomic
regions on chromosome 4 6 12 13 and 5
and then when we go to the clonal
evaluation trial for all the three
phenotypes that we evaluated we have
common genomic regions with their
uh population when we do look at
kyondo's paper you you see that we only
have common genomic regions for only
cbsd at six months after planting and
that's on chromosome 11 in the seedling
trial and chromosome 11 and 12 in the
clonal evaluation trial so having done
this the tech home message you could see
that chromosome 4 and chromosome 12
appear more frequently in between both
studies
between
the two studies and our research so the
take-home message i would like you to
take about cassava brown straight
disease is one we've identified snips
but you can clearly see that these snips
vary across uh
the three six and twelve months time
points of evaluation we've also seen
that these deeps vary between the
signaling and the clone evaluation trial
even if i didn't show the data they do
for they do vary across here so if you
test uh the snips that show up in 2019
and 2020 trials are very different steps
but also they're different across
populations we've also observed that in
in our study and also published studies
generally the snips that are identified
are small effects names so we we
acknowledge that there's uh their
genotype by environment interactions
that's the one to five scoring scale is
not picking up so moving forward now
that we know that cbsd is a complex
trait the next thing that we're trying
to work on is to do a meta-analysis
study for all the dua studies that have
been published that is uh data from
muzuki kyondo and my study to make that
i want to make that one study and see
which genomic regions would show up and
then in
in that we hope to identify you know
candidate gene move forward to develop
our cast markers for cbsd resistance
breeding then another thing we're trying
to do is we're trying to expand the
phenotyping methods because we
understand that we're not capturing all
the
interactions between all the components
that happen for cbsd to be in place so
we are expanding to include virus title
that's you know to go specific to how
these virus species behave with the
plant the virus plant interaction we're
also trying to
uh include imaging
to study root net process to try and uh
it's like expand how much information we
can get about the syst the the disease
symptoms and then um
we hope that that will be helpful to
identify genomic regions that are
associated with cassava brown straight
disease so i would like to thank my
committee that's made up of john look
michelle heck and kate perry the john
look and service lab and the root crops
department at the national crutch
resources research institute in uganda
i'll take any questions thank you
chat
oh so
walter is asking if there are any non uh
dominant resistance genes against
cassava bronze straight disease the
answer is no we do not know any
um i have a question
did you notice any
environmental characteristics that
explain some of the variable genetic
effects you saw
so
one is the
the locations of where we test the
we test the material right so one is a
high disease pressure place and another
is
a low or moderate disease pressure and
what we've noticed is that uh since we
depend on natural infections so that
means the white flies have to transmit
the viruses for us we tend to see that
in some locations you know one viral
species is more dominant than the other
so that could explain all these
inconsistencies
any other questions from the room
all right well yeah let's thank leah
thank you
so my research is kind of focusing on
the g by e uh problem um
and we know that correcting for
environment can enable better selections
and plant breeding when we talk about g
by e we can think about multi
location effects that come from just
disparate geographies but we can also
think about the local environment so
things within a single field
either from soil heterogeneity or
soil elevation
um that sort of thing
and so in the past um we've
uh
um we know that design randomizations
can help correct for these kinds of
local
um errors
and um
more recently there's been like new
statistical approaches
that um capture the
they capture the um
interdependence between
neighboring plots so that plots that are
closer to each other
have
[Music]
correlated or interdependent
so
in this research we're using the genomes
field hybrid maze experiments that are
planted at musgrave
research station here
and um
[Music]
we're
we're using this
to look at those local environment
effects that i was talking about
now um
we want we want to
see
if we can improve genomic prediction so
have to establish some baseline
genomic prediction models
as i'm sure you all
are aware
um here i'm just defining the model g
where we have um a random effect u
what that which follows uh
you know it's it's
variance is defined by this genomic
relationships so certain hybrids are
more related than others
um
and we compute g from genome-wide
markers
we can improve
we can improve on that
by taking into account spatial
corrections
so here i'm defining two models um
g plus 2d spline and g plus ar1 and what
these models do is they add an
additional random
effect
and that random effect is structured
uh to account for plots that are closer
to each other
will have that kind of interdependent
um
uh effect
now we can um apply
that spatially corrected model here i'm
showing the two-dimensional spline
effects
and i'm applying it to grain yield
ear height and
rain moisture in 2017.
these heat maps show a field level view
and we can see similar effects spatial
effects between grain yield and year
height
with kind of an inversion for grain
moisture
looking at 2019 again brain yield and
year height
show kind of similar
spatial patterns
and we saw that again in 2020
and these
spatial effects
they they can account for up to like
plus or minus 25
bushels
per acre
as
illustrated
but the question is can can we do better
using uavs
and so we um flew a uav
over over these field experiments in
uh 2015 2017
2019 and 2020.
that's the data i'm using and
we use this image breed program
to uh define the plot
and the plot level of polygons
onto the
aerial images
and
imagery that lets us then like
extract phenotypes for each plot
and there there's a lot of phenotypes
you can look at um
uh kind of neural networks are like a a
really interesting method
um for getting features out of images
and also from the drone you can get
these um
it's called a digital surface map so
it's like estimated
height
and those are all
very cool um things maybe for
future research
um but what i looked at was just ndvi
and ndvi's
this ratio of near infrared and red
and
um
it's a useful phenotype because uh
productive chlorophyll
reflects in the near infrared and
absorbs in the red and also the camera
we're usually using
is um
well suited for
uh collecting this
and so um
if i show here in 2020 um
on the x-axis is days after planting and
on the y
is just the mean the average ndvi
for these uh 15
hybrids we we could see consistent like
ndvi
uh
trajectories for each hybrid
um
starting at you know uh
the the vegetative or the the growth
early growth phase kind of plateauing
during the
um grain filling and then
senescent like dry down and senescence
at the end
and so this was um
like
promising
um vote
and and potentially useful in itself but
we wanted to um
try to improve genomic prediction and so
we thought a two-stage approach
could work so in the first stage we just
look at ndvi
and from ndvi we look at those local
environment effects
[Music]
so again the two-dimensional spline or
the ar1
spatial effect
and
a separate alternative model is to use
the random regression
which gives us a permanent environment
effect
and the the random regression is good
because
it can fit many many time points in a
single model
and it only leverages the fact these are
repeated measurements on the same
plots
so from the first stage we we end up
getting these
um
ndvi local environment effects across
time
and if we look at what
what those
ndvi spatial effects
how they compare to grain yield
uh here i'm showing a heat map of grain
yield itself of the
spatial effect of grain yield and of the
spatial effect of ndvi at
38 days after planting so you see a
similar kind of spatial pattern
between those and if you look at kind of
the whole field experiment i mean the
whole seas growing season
from 38 days after planting up to uh
133 days after planting
you see that the grain yield
the spatial effects
for grain yield
correlate pretty highly with
the spatial effects of ndvi
even early on
so at 38 days after planting you we saw
uh
uh
0.5
and then up to 0.7
so
that that you know that summarizes the
first stage but in the second stage we
wanted to
include those um ndvi local
environmental effects
and
we could
we we looked at two different approaches
for doing this
um so again here
uh
we're adding a random effect
um up
um so
that uh random effects variance um
follows this
this uh l matrix
which is like a
for all the plots in the field like how
related are those plots to each other
and um l is like a
it's a correlation of those
ndvi
spatial effects
but um the second way which is more
simple is just to put a fixed effect
so h average here which is just an
average of all those
ndvi
spatial effects
um but you can think
to go further and separate
uh h into different ranges so like
uh you have
h1 going from
um
kind of the the early part of the
growing season the middle and the late
so we looked at those models and we
looked at irritability and genotypic
effect estimation
so irritability you know is is the
genetic additive genetic variance
over the
with the residual variants
but genotypic effect
estimation is where we
separated the field into
its replicates
so we define
two replicas here
then you you run you run one of these
two stage models on
on each
block and then you see
how correlated the genetic effects are
to each other
and we think this is a really useful
metric for
determining if the
spatial correction is actually working
and um
so
in in conclusion um
we saw that
the
two stage models
um tend to improve
uh these metrics
and um
[Music]
but we need more date more years to
really validate this
and i'd like to thank uh
the province and the mueller labs and
if you have any questions
be happy to answer them
so how early in the season can you start
scoring from the drone
so
really
i think um
about 30 30 days after planting um
you can
start to see the plants uh
well in the images
since we fly like that 20 meters so
you know
the resolution's not
not super great
can can you fly lower or not
uh you can but um the battery life isn't
like you have like 30 or 40 minutes of
battery
and if you fly lower then
it'll take longer
so
okay
cool thank you
sure
thanks you had every other year data do
you have more data or
was it not done
yeah so um jim asked if
if i had like 2018 2016 and so on um
yeah we we have that data but um
it wasn't working too well um and
um
i've focused on on these four years
um yeah thank you for the introduction
um today i'll be talking about my
progress in gene expression profiling
and correlation with structural variants
to understand the link between genotypic
and phenotypic diversity specifically
intra major
so each organism differs in their
genetic sequence and this variation or
also variance can range in length from
just like one base pair to several
hundreds of kilobase pairs
and thereby anything that is larger than
50 base pairs is called a structural
variant or abbreviated sb
examples for structural variants are
something like inversions translocations
or fusions but also copy number variants
cnvs such as insertions or deletions
duplications of parts of chromosomes or
even duplications of whole chromosomes
it has been shown that structural
variants make up the majority of genomic
differences between species and between
different culture vices they often also
are the causal elia with very large
effect size because they're so like long
however structural variants are
underrepresented in the predominantly
used short read sequencing
so that
even though structural variants might
often be the causative effect for
specific qtls they are not detected in
previous g walls which identify qdl via
snips
it was also shown
like with the use of or more increased
use of long-range sequencing
more studies focus on structural
variants now in plants as well
and those studies have identified that
structural variants oftentimes overlap
with genes or regulatory sequences and
thus they affect the expression of those
genes and they can influence the
expression for example by altering the
gene sequence itself by altering copy
number of that gene or by changing the
position or the sequence of cis
regulatory elements
so i'm interested in understanding the
genetic regulation of fruit ripening
and the model organism that is used in
looking at like fruit ripening
specifically fleshy fruits that show
ripening phenotypes or they continue
ripening after you harvest the fruit or
tomato
tomato are also one of the most
important vegetable crops and we see a
quite wide variation in phenotypes and
tomato although the genetic basis is
quite narrow
so all for all these reasons i'm using
tomato in my research
and two recent papers
both
published in 2020 study structural
variants in tomatoes the first one on
the left by elongated
and they identified structural variants
in a diversity population of 100 tomato
species
and so structural variants are always
called or defined in reference to the
heinz reference genome which is a modern
culture mark
so you can see on the left here
while tomato species have many more
structural variants
while commercial
tomatoes or modern varieties
varieties have
fewer structural variants and most
structural variants are either insertion
or deletions
and then the second paper
they looked at the researchers looked at
structural variants specifically between
one wild species and the heinz
tomato reference genome and then they
identified a total of 92 000 structural
variants
um so our recent goal in genetics is to
understand how structural variants
influence gene expression and while
those two studies have looked into this
a little bit they must be focused on the
identification of structural variants
um so this is where my research
plays role
we want to use the available structure
of variance from those two studies
and then basically
build a resource for gene expression
profiles that can be correlated with the
available structural variants as well as
with agriculturally important phenotypes
such as um or a phenotypes that are
related to fruit ripening and
nutritional quality of fruit
specifically tomato again
to this end i have my major project
look at a tomato diversity piano of 177
accessions so i have all of these
growing in greenhouses over like the
last year
and i'm harvesting fruit pericarp flour
and leaf material for gene expression
analyses and i'm also looking at
different phenotypes such as sleeve size
fruit morphology and nutritional
compositions of the fruit
for a second project which is a smaller
site project
i'm looking at high resolution gene
expression profiles for one of the wild
species that is part of my diversity
piano
and for this plant i am specifically
looking at four distinct cell types of
the fruit period carb
um so this map shows where tomatoes are
grown worldwide and mostly identic
identifies or indicates where the five
tomato species are from that are part of
my diversity piano
those include solanum cheese mania and
galapagos which are from the galapagos
islands
wild species and then a third white
species solanum tempinilifolium which is
the only red colored wild species and is
the progenitor of our commercial to
major lines
then as per commercial lines i included
like a persicum variety survey for me
which is an early domesticated tomato
line and then like a persicum variety
like a persicum which was our like big
fruited modern tomato
as i mentioned on the slide before i
harvested leaf material flower material
and then fruit material are three
different developmental stages which
armature green which is when the seeds
are mature but the fruit is still green
break your stage which is when the
fruits start accumulating carotenoids
and ripe stage which is defined as
breaker plus seven days in my study
and i harvested the pericarp which in
this diagram here you can see is the
green colored
tissue
okay um so all the samples are frozen in
the freezer and step by step are being
processed for rna and different
metabolites
this image here shows a
kind of a collection of some of the
tomato fruit and it's specifically
interesting because it shows the
different phenotypes including color
size and form
and although we don't have gene
expression data for fruit yet over the
last summer i looked at retinoid
profiles with one of
a high school intern over the summer
um and i'm not going to go into the
details of the carotenoid profiles here
but we did see variation between the
different accessions
which was really interesting and once we
get the gene expression data we can
correlate structural variants not only
with the gene expression but also with
nutrient compositions
okay
similar to the fruit we can see a lot of
morphological
variation in leaf shapes
specifically between but also within
species
and to uh quantify this variation within
leaves we send leaf material to the
nelima sinha lab at uc davis where her
graduate student carl
did
like
mathematical measures
um on the samples to get like a
quantitative analysis of leaf shape
and then also over the last summary with
an reu intern
um we looked at
gene expression data from leaves that we
had available for 36 tomato accessions
and we also have the structural variant
data from the genos from
the two studies that i mentioned at the
beginning
so the first thing we did was to map our
rna expression data to the reference
genome to get gene expression data for
the 35 000 genes in tomato
and then we looked at structural
variance presence or absence in the 36
tomato accessions
and we
we started by looking at structural
variants that overlap with genes
and within these 36 tomato accession
genomes we got 5 500 structural variant
gene pairs so where the structural
variant is within the gene
um to narrow down
this number or to specifically look for
svg in pairs that are present in at
least five accessions and absence absent
in at least five accessions
um we filtered these 5 500 and got to 3
500 structural variant gene pairs
um
and then when you do like a differential
gene expression analysis you usually
have two groups you have like a
your wild type and you have a treatment
like a normal under treatment and in our
case we um split the accessions which is
why we needed at least five width and at
least five without the presence or
absence of the structural variant
and so we split those accessions into
those with the structure of the urine
and those without the structural
variance
and then did differential expressions
like a
significance test
for all of the structural variant gene
pairs that we have
so from this list we found 271
statistically significant structural
variant gene pairs so all these 271 show
differential for significant
differential expression for whether they
had or did not have that structural
variance
and from from this 271 103 genes
overlapped with a set of literature
created genes that play role in leaf
development and the
most significant of those structural
variant gene piers
actually showed a significant impact
on the leaflet phenotypes
in the
leaf
quantitative measurement study so it
showed significant impact over all five
of the principal components that were
used
for this mathematical study um and we
could also see in photos that we took of
our planes that those leaves without the
structural variant
had a more uniform aspect ratio of the
leaf and those with that with the
structural variant had
more like
serrating and loading density and the
structural variant itself has a 143 base
pair insertion into a tomato gene that
encodes a two oxyglutarate and iron
oxygen superfamily protein
and i don't have more information
unfortunately about the structural
variant or the regulation but this is
something i'll be looking at into over
the next few months
um so just quickly um talking about my
second smallie project
which is where i said i'm looking at
high-resolution gene expression data um
specific for this one wild type which is
part of my diversity panel as well
um the
leaf or the the cell types i'm looking
at
are within the fruit
and they are they are the outer
epidermis colenchyma parenchyma and
vascular tissue
um
and i'm also looking at three different
developmental stages similar to the
diversity panel i'm looking at mature
green breaker and breakthrough seventh
stage
um and so how do you get to those
different cell types um i'm basically um
i have to prepare my samples i cut off
the pericarp the fruit are quite small
so they fit into a mode
they are directly embedded in a medium
frozen and cryoception onto specific
microscopes lights and then with those
microscopes lights i go to a laser
capture micro dissection microscope
and then cut out the specific cells that
i want
i have to do rna extraction on those
cells amplification and then i can
sequence their rnas
um so here you can see a picture from my
sample under the
lcm it's under the microscope on the
left you can see a photo of the
autofluorescence you can see the
different cell types and on the right
you can see
my sample under bright field you can
also see the different cell types but
specifically here you can see how i cut
out an area of the leaf um
and this is like on a pet membrane so
it's like a specific slide that i can
cut my my cells out
um and i have not um
or at this point i've only done a few
like um
trial slides to see how the laser works
and how well i can cut my samples um but
i will hopefully soon get to the point
where i can cut out my specific cells
and then do the rna sequencing on it
okay so all together i could show that
with my project i can
correlate structural variants with gene
expression and phenotype data
um and that's those structural variant
studies can provide insights into the
genotype to phenotype relationship
um ultimately i would like to look into
more structural variants
um that specifically in like the
utrs and in intergenic regions because
so far i only looked at those within
gene sequences
um i'll also call more structural
variants on genotypes that have not been
called for structural variants in the
two studies that i mentioned
and most interestingly i am excited to
look
at gene expression data from fruit and
then specifically look at ripening
phenotypes and the effect of structural
variants on those phenotypes
both in the pericarp as well as like the
single
cell types
okay and with that i would like to thank
everyone in my lab
my committee members collaborators green
house staff and my interns and you for
listening
and i'm happy to take questions
travis
so
for the svg
um so the question was for the svg and
here's if i'm looking at
like axons versus introns or the
promoter regions um so far we've only
looked at
structural variants that are within
i think axons and introns
we have not looked at promoter regions
yet but that's something that we're
specifically interested in to see if
there's like structural variant effect
on gene expression through
promoter regions or assess regulatory
other cis-regulatory regions
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu